As the crispy chicken sandwich from 7-Eleven, people always call me loud. And I'm like, yeah, I know. I'm crispy. Did you expect me to whisper? If you want quiet, go eat some soup and reflect. Like, I know I'm a handful. I'm bold, I'm juicy. Throw some pickles and barbecue sauce on me, and baby, I'm a whole meal.
作为7-Eleven的脆皮鸡三明治，人们总说我声音大。我心想，是啊，我知道。我很脆。难道你指望我耳语吗？如果你想要安静，去喝点汤反思一下吧。我是说，我知道我很难搞。我大胆，我多汁。给我撒点酸黄瓜和烧烤酱，宝贝，我就是一顿完整的大餐。
And with seven rewards, I'm just $4. Quiet. No. Krispy, saucy, and $4? Very. Only at 711. Valley 362326, participating stores only while supplies lastly out for full terms. The first confirmed case of COVID-19 in the U.S. was identified in January.
有了7-Eleven的奖励，我只要4美元。安静？不。脆皮、多汁、只要4美元？非常可以。仅限7-Eleven。编号362326，仅限参与活动的门店，售完即止，详情请见完整条款。美国首例新冠肺炎确诊病例于1月被发现。
By March, most of us had been strongly advised, if not ordered, to keep at least six feet away from other people in public and pretty much to confine ourselves to our homes. As a result, many of us are unable to visit friends or family. We can't go out to a movie, to the gym, or out to dinner. In short, the coronavirus has radically curtailed the way many of us live. So are we bored yet? And if we are bored, is that a problem? Is boredom bad? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that explores the links between psychology and everyday life.
到了三月，我们大多数人都被强烈建议，甚至被要求在公共场合与他人保持至少六英尺的距离，并基本上把自己限制在家里。结果，我们许多人无法探望朋友或家人。我们不能出去看电影、去健身房或外出就餐。简而言之，冠状病毒从根本上限制了我们许多人的生活方式。那么我们感到无聊了吗？如果我们感到无聊，这是一个问题吗？无聊是坏事吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探索心理学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. What does psychology tell us about boredom? And why should we care? Is boredom even a legitimate area for psychologists to study? What can we do during these strange times to keep from being bored? Or to use our boredom productively? Our guest today is Dr. Aaron Westgate, an assistant professor of psychology at the University of Florida, where she studies boredom, interest, and why some thoughts are more engaging than others. Much of her research has been on the conditions under which people enjoy or do not enjoy their own thoughts.
我是金·米尔斯。心理学告诉我们关于无聊的什么？我们为什么要关心它？无聊甚至是一个心理学家研究的合法领域吗？在这个奇怪的时期，我们能做些什么来避免无聊？或者如何高效地利用我们的无聊？我们今天的嘉宾是佛罗里达大学心理学助理教授亚伦·韦斯特盖特博士，她研究无聊、兴趣以及为什么有些想法比其他想法更吸引人。她的许多研究都集中在人们享受或不享受自己想法的条件下。
Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Westgate. Thank you so much for having me. Let me start by throwing you a big softball. So what is boredom and how is it different from other states of mental inactivity? So boredom is actually an emotion. There's often a lot of confusion about this. Like, is boredom actually a feeling I have? Is it an emotion? Is it a state where I'm not feeling anything at all? We actually, there's been a lot of debate in psychology about this, but the growing consensus is that boredom is an emotion like any other that you experience, like anger or sadness. And that we define it as those cases where you're not able to. engage meaningfully in whatever it is that you're doing, either because you're not able to pay attention or because whatever it is that you're doing just doesn't feel meaningful to you. Well, as I mentioned a moment ago, a lot of us are stuck in our homes with very little to distract us.
欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，韦斯特盖特博士。非常感谢邀请我。让我先抛出一个简单的问题。那么什么是无聊，它与其他精神不活跃的状态有什么不同？所以无聊实际上是一种情绪。关于这一点通常有很多困惑。比如，无聊真的是我的一种感觉吗？它是一种情绪吗？它是我什么感觉都没有的状态吗？实际上，心理学界对此有很多争论，但越来越多的共识是，无聊就像你经历的任何其他情绪一样，比如愤怒或悲伤。我们将其定义为那些你无法有意义地参与你正在做的事情的情况，要么是因为你无法集中注意力，要么是因为你正在做的事情对你来说感觉没有意义。嗯，正如我刚才提到的，我们很多人被困在家里，几乎没有什么能分散我们的注意力。
Are you hearing that boredom is on the rise as a result of the COVID-19 pandemic? There's some interesting research out of Italy, actually, that looked at folks in quarantine right now that suggests that they themselves said that the second biggest sort of downside to being stuck at home was lack of freedom first, obviously. But the second most problematic thing that they were experiencing was boredom, even more than the social isolation and feelings of loneliness. So I think it really depends a lot. I think certainly there are some people who may be home-schooling kids and trying to work from home
你是否听说由于新冠疫情，无聊感正在上升？实际上，意大利有一些有趣的研究，观察了目前处于隔离状态的人们，这表明他们自己说，被困在家里的第二大缺点是缺乏自由，当然第一大缺点显而易见。但他们经历的第二大问题是无聊，甚至超过了社交隔离和孤独感。所以我认为这真的取决于很多因素。我认为肯定有一些人可能在家里教孩子并试图在家工作，
and who are not bored that if anything, they may be feeling overwhelmed and anxious. But I think there's an awful lot of us who are at home and suddenly find ourselves without the routines that structured our lives or the tasks that we've spent most of our days doing and stuck with those long sort of periods of time with nothing to do and limits on what you can do about it. I think a lot of us are feeling a bit bored. What made you want to study boredom? Were you sort of in a state of boredom and it hit you that, wow, this is something I need to think about? You know, it's always, I always get a laugh when I tell people I study boredom. We're like, oh, like, you always grew up wanting to like be a boredom researcher. No, absolutely not.
他们并不感到无聊，如果说有什么的话，他们可能感到不知所措和焦虑。但我认为我们中有很多人在家里，突然发现自己没有了构建我们生活的常规，也没有了我们大部分时间都在做的任务，被困在那些漫长的、无事可做的时期，而且对你能做的事情有限制。我想我们很多人都感到有点无聊。是什么让你想研究无聊？你当时是否处于一种无聊的状态，然后突然意识到，哇，这是我需要思考的事情？你知道，每次我告诉别人我研究无聊时，我总是会引来笑声。他们会说，哦，就像你从小就想成为一名无聊研究员一样。不，绝对不是。
I don't think that's anything little kids is spying. Haven't heard that one from a kid yet. No, right? Like, oh, I really want to study boredom one day. I sort of fell into studying boredom because I was doing earlier work on whether people enjoy being alone with their own thoughts. So we all find ourselves stuck at times, such as at the stoplight or just, you know, waiting in line when it would be nice if we could sort of sit back mentally and daydream or just sort of enjoy our own thoughts. And when I started graduate school, I was interested in this question. I started doing research on this question and found that a lot of us really struggled to do this.
我不认为这是小孩子会向往的事情。还没从孩子那里听到过这个。不，对吧？就像，哦，我真的想有一天研究无聊。我之所以开始研究无聊，是因为我之前做过关于人们是否喜欢独自思考的工作。所以我们都会发现自己有时会被困住，比如在红绿灯处，或者只是，你知道，排队时，如果我们能在精神上坐下来做白日梦，或者只是享受自己的想法，那该多好。当我开始读研究生时，我对这个问题很感兴趣。我开始对这个问题进行研究，发现我们很多人真的很难做到这一点。
It's not as easy to simply sit back and intentionally have a pleasant daydream as you might think. And in one study, for instance, we even found that when you ask people to do this on demand in the laboratory, we don't, you know, sit down, try to think for pleasure. But if you want, you can shock yourself with this little electric shock here. About 67% of the men and 25% of the women chose to shock themselves rather than just sit and think. And when we asked them why, they kind of looked at us like, well done. They were like, well, it was really boring. I hope because that's such not an answer, you know. Yeah.
简单地坐下来有意地进行愉快的白日梦并不像你想象的那么容易。例如，在一项研究中，我们甚至发现，当你要求人们在实验室里按需这样做时，我们不会，你知道，坐下来尝试为了快乐而思考。但如果你愿意，你可以用这个小电击器电击自己。大约67%的男性和25%的女性选择电击自己，而不是仅仅坐着思考。当我们问他们为什么时，他们看着我们的样子就像，做得好。他们说，嗯，这真的很无聊。我希望是因为那根本不是一个答案，你知道。是的。
I was bored, so I shocked myself. And I was so intrigued by that question. And I sort of pivoted a little from like, why do people enjoy daydreaming? Why is it so hard to daydream? To like, what is this strange state that makes people willing to shock themselves? Why are they bored? Can we figure out how to make people not bored?
我很无聊，所以我电击了自己。我对那个问题非常着迷。我从“为什么人们喜欢做白日梦”稍微转向了“为什么做白日梦这么难”，转向了“这种让人们愿意电击自己的奇怪状态是什么？”他们为什么无聊？我们能找出如何让人们不无聊的方法吗？
And can we understand what people do when they are? our board. So I really had a sort of a shift that came out of the research I was doing and what the participants themselves were telling us. And I realized, I like to say, boredom is actually pretty interesting. And that's not something I would have, I would have said 10 years ago before I started doing this work. So that's an interesting study that you did. And I know that you found differences between men and women. And I'm also wondering, I mean, you can talk about that in a moment, but did people shock themselves more than once? I mean, was it just out of curiosity, or do they just sit there and do it a couple of times? Because what the heck? You know,
我们能理解人们在无聊时会做什么吗？所以我确实经历了一种转变，这源于我正在做的研究以及参与者自己告诉我们的内容。我意识到，我喜欢说，无聊其实很有趣。这不是我10年前在开始这项工作之前会说的话。所以这是一个你做的有趣的研究。我知道你发现了男性和女性之间的差异。我也在想，我的意思是，你可以一会儿再谈谈那个，但人们电击自己不止一次吗？我的意思是，这只是出于好奇，还是他们只是坐在那里做了几次？因为这到底是怎么回事？你知道，
it's the darndest thing. They did it multiple times. I know. I know. We were like, the results came in and we were like, well, let's give people the benefit of the doubt. Maybe they, you know, just wanted to see if we, maybe they wanted to call our bluff. Maybe they weren't sure if we were really serious about it or maybe they just wanted to see what would happen. But the majority of people that shocked themselves shocked themselves more than once. And we had one person who we actually excluded from the data because he shocked himself like over, I forget now, it's over like 75 times. Wow. And it was only a- He was having a good time, huh? Or something. It was only a 20-minute period or a 15-minute period. So we actually had a research assistant go back and see if our machine was even
这是最奇怪的事情。他们做了多次。我知道。我知道。我们当时想，结果出来了，我们想，好吧，让我们给人们一点信任。也许他们，你知道，只是想看看我们，也许他们想看看我们是否在虚张声势。也许他们不确定我们是否真的认真，或者也许他们只是想看看会发生什么。但大多数电击自己的人不止一次地电击了自己。我们有一个人，我们实际上把他从数据中排除了，因为他电击了自己超过，我现在忘了，超过75次。哇。而且那只是一个——他玩得很开心，是吧？或者类似的事情。那只是一个20分钟或15分钟的时间段。所以我们实际上让一位研究助理回去看看我们的机器是否甚至
capable of shocking so that many times. Like maybe like the machine was broken. So this wonderful undergraduate research assistant for science sat there and shocked herself like a hundred times just to see if the machine would work. Wow. So yeah, we don't think it was something like just calling our bluff or, and the other thing is that all these people, we gave them a taste to the shock up front. We had them experience it and rate it. They could tell us whether they enjoyed it or didn't enjoy it. And everyone basically says they don't enjoy it. And we said, okay. Like imagine we give you $5, how much would you pay to not be shocked again? And most of these people that went on to shock themselves said they'd pay on average about $2 to not be shocked. Yeah, I know, I know. It's like we're strangers to ourselves. It's a failure of imagination.
能够电击那么多次。就像也许机器坏了。所以这位出色的本科研究助理为了科学坐在那里，电击了自己一百次，只是为了看看机器是否能工作。哇。所以是的，我们不认为这仅仅是虚张声势，而且另一件事是，所有这些人，我们事先让他们体验了电击。我们让他们体验并评价它。他们可以告诉我们他们是否喜欢它或不喜欢它。每个人基本上都说他们不喜欢它。我们说，好吧。就像想象我们给你5美元，你愿意付多少钱来不再被电击？大多数继续电击自己的人说，他们平均愿意支付大约2美元来避免被电击。是的，我知道，我知道。这就像我们对自己是陌生人。这是想象力的失败。
I think we don't know how we're going to feel in the future. I think we don't realize how boring something might be and how motivated we can feel when we are bored to do something. even to do anything to stop feeling that way. So that raises a question for me, which is whether there's anything useful about boredom or is it detrimental or is it somehow both? D, all of the above. Bortem is useful when it's working correctly. So I always like to say that boredom is like pain.
我认为我们不知道未来会有什么感觉。我认为我们没有意识到某件事可能会有多无聊，以及当我们感到无聊时，我们会有多大的动力去做某事。甚至去做任何事情来停止那种感觉。所以这对我提出了一个问题，即无聊是否有任何有用的地方，还是它是有害的，或者它在某种程度上两者兼有？以上皆是。当无聊正常工作时，它是很有用的。所以我总是喜欢说无聊就像疼痛。
No one wants to experience pain. Pain is unpleasant. It hurts. But it's also really, really useful because it tells us that there's, something wrong going on in our bodies. And it's a way of alerting us to that problem and motivating us to take steps to stop it. Right. And boredom and other negative emotions as well act in the same way. Bortem tells us, hey, look, something is wrong. In this case that we either can't pay attention to what we're doing because it's too hard or too easy, but because what we're doing doesn't feel
没有人想经历疼痛。疼痛是不愉快的。它很痛。但它也非常、非常有益，因为它告诉我们，我们的身体里出了问题。这是一种提醒我们注意那个问题并激励我们采取措施停止它的方法。对。无聊和其他负面情绪也以同样的方式起作用。无聊告诉我们，嘿，看，出了问题。在这种情况下，我们要么无法关注我们正在做的事情，因为它太难或太容易，要么是因为我们正在做的事情感觉
meaningful to us. But whatever it is, boredom says, stop. This is hurting us mentally. Can you something about it. And so boredom is really important because it signals instances to us when we're not meaningfully engaged in the world. And it gives us an opportunity to fix it. That said, that's only healthy and adaptive in cases where you can do something about it. If you're trapped, for instance, in a room by psychologists with nothing else to do, but shock yourself, there's not really any good solution available to you. So in that case, boredom is an adaptive signal, but it can come a problem when we don't have good options on the table to fix it. If you're stuck in the room and you have nothing
对我们来说没有意义。但无论是什么，无聊都在说，停下来。这在精神上伤害了我们。你能为此做点什么吗？所以无聊非常重要，因为它向我们发出了信号，表明我们没有有意义地参与到这个世界中。它给了我们一个修复它的机会。话虽如此，这只有在你能够为此做点什么的情况下才是健康和适应性的。例如，如果你被心理学家困在一个房间里，除了电击自己之外别无他法，那么你并没有什么好的解决方案。所以在那种情况下，无聊是一个适应性信号，但当我们没有好的选择来解决它时，它就会成为一个问题。如果你被困在房间里，你什么都没有
figuratively to do to stop feeling bored other than to shock yourself, then people will shock themselves. And that obviously is not good. So I do like the analogy that boredom is like pain. It's healthy and useful and important information, but it can become chronic. And, like, it becomes chronic, it doesn't serve as that useful signal anymore. And we can vary in the ways we respond to it. We really want to treat the underlying cause of that pain or that boredom. We don't want to just treat the bad feelings and make them go away without fixing those underlying issues. That sounds almost like boredom can morph into depression. Is that what happens to us?
比喻地说，除了电击自己之外，没有别的方法可以停止感到无聊，那么人们就会电击自己。这显然是不好的。所以我确实喜欢无聊就像疼痛的类比。它是健康、有用和重要的信息，但它可能会变成慢性的。而且，当它变成慢性时，它就不再作为那个有用的信号了。我们对它的反应方式可能会有所不同。我们真的想治疗那种疼痛或无聊的根本原因。我们不想只是治疗坏情绪，在不解决那些根本问题的情况下让它们消失。这听起来几乎像是无聊可以演变成抑郁症。这就是发生在我们身上的事情吗？
It's not clear. There's a lot of discussion and debate right now on what exactly the relationship is between boredom and depression. Boredom is certainly a feature of depression in many cases. People who are depressed often talk about a lack of motivation, an inability to find anything meaningful. They struggle to pay attention. These are all things we see in boredom and many depressed people report feeling bored a lot. What's not clear is if depression causes boredom, or if boredom causes depression, or what I think maybe most likely is, that situations that cause chronic boredom, so being in situations where you're sort of stuck where you don't have any good options on the table, that's going to make you bored,
目前还不清楚。现在关于无聊和抑郁症之间的确切关系有很多讨论和争论。在许多情况下，无聊当然是抑郁症的一个特征。抑郁的人经常谈论缺乏动力，无法找到任何有意义的东西。他们难以集中注意力。这些都是我们在无聊中看到的事情，许多抑郁的人报告说经常感到无聊。不清楚的是，是抑郁导致了无聊，还是无聊导致了抑郁，或者我认为最可能的是，导致慢性无聊的情况，即处于某种被困住、没有好的选择的情况，那会让你感到无聊，
that's also over time going to make you depressed, independent of whether you're bored or not. So I think it's very complicated, and that's one of the, you know, there's a few questions that I think that are really at the forefront of boredom research right now. I think that's one of them is untangling how boredom and depression and a lot of really maladaptive behaviors associated with both of them, like substance use and alcohol use, how they're all interrelated, and who's causing who? Oh, good questions. So are you using brain scans, fMRIs, things like that, to determine when people say they're bored or can you tell based on what their brains look like, whether they're experiencing something other than boredom? So we usually, in studies of boredom and all emotion
随着时间的推移，这也会让你感到抑郁，无论你是否无聊。所以我认为这非常复杂，我认为这是目前无聊研究最前沿的几个问题之一。我认为其中之一就是理清无聊、抑郁以及与两者相关的许多非常适应不良的行为（如物质使用和酒精使用）是如何相互关联的，以及谁导致了谁？哦，好问题。那么你是否正在使用脑部扫描、功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）等方法来确定人们说他们无聊时的情况，或者你能根据他们大脑的样子判断他们是否正在经历除无聊之外的事情吗？所以我们通常在无聊和所有情绪的研究中
really rely pretty face validly on what people tell us. There's been a lot of, of debate in psychology about how do you best measure something like happiness or you measure it best measure something like boredom. And the consensus is largely that the best most reliable way is to simply ask people what they're feeling. Now, people can't tell you why they're feeling that way. If they try, if you ask them, why are you bored? They may have theories for it. They may have causal ideas for it and they may think that's why they're bored, but we know that people can't actually accurately introspect on those things. They can't actually tell us why they're board because we don't have access to that information mentally, but they can tell us what they're
确实非常依赖人们告诉我们的内容。心理学界关于如何最好地衡量像幸福这样的东西，或者你如何最好地衡量像无聊这样的东西，有很多争论。共识很大程度上是，最好、最可靠的方法就是简单地询问人们他们的感受。现在，人们无法告诉你他们为什么会有那种感觉。如果他们尝试，如果你问他们，你为什么无聊？他们可能会有理论，他们可能会有因果想法，他们可能会认为这就是他们无聊的原因，但我们知道人们实际上无法准确地内省这些事情。他们实际上无法告诉我们他们为什么无聊，因为我们在精神上无法获得那些信息，但他们可以告诉我们他们
feeling. There is some work looking at boredom in terms of sort of neuroscience. There's not a lot of it. Most of it's been done by James Denkert and his crew out of Canada. I haven't gone that much that direction, partly because of the work by Kristen Lindquist and Lisa Feldman Barrett and others that suggest that there aren't really good neuro markers of specific emotions in the brain that when you look at anger and sadness and fear, people's brains all kind of look pretty similar, that you can't really reliably distinguish one emotion from each other. So I think there's lots of important neuroscience to be done in boredom, but it's not a direction that I've really pursued. That's interesting. So the neurons just fire no matter what. You're feeling something intense,
感觉如何。有一些关于神经科学方面无聊的研究。这方面的研究不多。大部分是由加拿大的詹姆斯·丹克特和他的团队完成的。我没有走那么多方向，部分原因是克里斯汀·林奎斯特、丽莎·费尔德曼·巴雷特和其他人的工作表明，大脑中并没有真正好的特定情绪的神经标记，当你观察愤怒、悲伤和恐惧时，人们的大脑看起来都非常相似，你无法真正可靠地将一种情绪与另一种情绪区分开来。所以我认为关于无聊还有很多重要的神经科学研究要做，但这并不是我真正追求的方向。这很有趣。所以神经元无论如何都会放电。你正在感受某种强烈的东西，
and that's what they see. We're still working on that question, but we do think that what seems to be happening is that there's an affective response. When we say affect, meaning like emotion, that when people are feeling lots of big emotions, you do see lots of activation in the brain. But it's hard to tell just from looking at the brain, whether that's an anger response or a fear response or what exactly is going on in those cases. Back in the days when I used to be able to go outside and see people, I would notice a lot of folks had their phones in their hands all the time, we're using smartphones, tablets, computers constantly. Is that having an impact on our ability to experience boredom? Are we keeping ourselves away from the normal experience of boredom by substituting
这就是他们看到的。我们仍在研究这个问题，但我们确实认为正在发生的事情是一种情感反应。当我们说情感，意思是像情绪，当人们感受到许多强烈的情绪时，你确实会看到大脑中有大量的激活。但仅从观察大脑很难判断那是愤怒反应还是恐惧反应，或者在这些情况下到底发生了什么。在我过去能够外出见到人们的日子里，我会注意到很多人一直拿着手机，一直在使用智能手机、平板电脑、电脑。这对我们体验无聊的能力有影响吗？我们是否通过替代这些屏幕来让自己远离正常的无聊体验？
these screens? You know, that's a question that I always get. And the quick answer is we don't know. Certainly, if you look throughout history, like, every generation has had its version of a smartphone. If you look back far enough, if you start seeing people complain about newspapers, how people are just, you know, reading on the subway instead of being the attention to that. Right, right. Novels were the big vice back in the day when they first came out. Like, oh, people are like ignoring the world for these fake mellow dramas that aren't even real.
你知道，这是一个我总是被问到的问题。简短的回答是我们不知道。当然，如果你纵观历史，每一代人都有自己的智能手机版本。如果你回顾得足够远，如果你开始看到人们抱怨报纸，人们是如何只是，你知道，在地铁上阅读而不是关注那个。对，对。小说在刚出来的时候是当时的一大恶习。就像，哦，人们为了这些甚至不真实的虚假情节剧而忽略了世界。
So I, you know, I really wish I had a time machine as a social psychologist. I like, you know, people always ask, look, if you had a superpower, what would you do? I would time travel and I would take my questionnaires and my studies and I'd go back in time and see. What we do know is when we look at, this isn't exactly boredom, but we do know that when you look at who is best able to daydream or enjoy their own thoughts, there is a very, very, very, very small but significant correlation between the amount of time people spend on their cell phones. and the extent to which they get bored when trying to daydream that the more time you spend on your phones, you're probably a little bit more likely to be someone that has difficulty enjoying your own thoughts and not getting bored by them. Again, is that causal? Is it that the cell phone use is causing people to have a hard time finding their own thoughts interesting? Or is it that people that are sort of prone to boredom are more likely to pick up their phone? That's really tricky.
所以我，你知道，我真的希望我作为一名社会心理学家有一台时间机器。我喜欢，你知道，人们总是问，看，如果你有一种超能力，你会做什么？我会穿越时空，我会带着我的问卷和研究回到过去看看。我们所知道的是，当我们观察时，这不完全是无聊，但我们确实知道，当你观察谁最能做白日梦或享受自己的想法时，人们花在手机上的时间与他们试图做白日梦时感到无聊的程度之间存在一个非常、非常、非常、非常小但显著的相关性，你花在手机上的时间越多，你可能越容易成为一个难以享受自己想法而不感到无聊的人。同样，这是因果关系吗？是手机使用导致人们难以发现自己的想法有趣吗？还是容易感到无聊的人更有可能拿起手机？这真的很棘手。
There was a study. This isn't boredom exactly, but there was a study recently. that paid people to not go on social media for a couple of weeks. And they did find that it increased people's happiness and well-being when you sort of paid them to stay off of these social media sites for a while. I know. I guess I'm doomed to be unhappy. Well, another question that occurs to me is whether there's any kind of a link
有一项研究。这不完全是无聊，但最近有一项研究。付钱给人们让他们几周不上社交媒体。他们确实发现，当你付钱让他们远离这些社交媒体网站一段时间时，这增加了人们的幸福感和幸福感。我知道。我想我注定要不快乐。好吧，另一个出现在我脑海中的问题是，整体智力与无聊之间是否有任何联系。更聪明的人是否更不容易感到无聊，因为他们拥有更大的智力资源，还是我在这里对聪明人有偏见？嗯，我认为这既是福也是祸，因为你可能因为两个原因感到无聊。一个是当某事太难时你会感到无聊。当然，拥有更多的认知资源肯定会减少某事对你来说太难的次数。你只是有更高的基线机会发现它很有趣。但无聊也是由太简单的事情引起的。
between, say, overall intelligence and boredom. Are smarter people more likely to not be bored because they've got greater intellectual resources, or am I just prejudiced in favor of smart people here? Well, I think it's a blessing and a curse because you can get bored for two reasons. One is you can get bored when something is too hard. And certainly having sort of more cognitive resources to bring to the table is going to reduce the times when something is too hard for you. you simply sort of have a higher baseline chance of finding it interesting. But boredom is also caused by things that are too easy.
所以实际上有研究，我很抱歉告诉你实际上有研究，一些研究表明，智商较高或对认知需求较高的人可能更容易受到无聊的影响，特别是当它是由重复、单调的任务引起时，正是因为他们有太多的资源，如果你坐在那里，你有10个资源，而这个单调、无聊的事情只占用了其中的两个。
And so there's actually research, I'm so sorry to tell you that there's actually research, some research that suggests that people with higher IQ or higher need for cognition may be sort of more susceptible to boredom, especially when it's caused by like repetitive monotonous tasks, precisely because they have so many resources, that if you're like, you're sitting there and you have like, say, 10 resources and this monotonous, boring thing is only occupying two of them.
你正在做的事情和你本可以做的事情之间存在巨大的差距。当这种情况发生时，我们发现很难集中注意力，这会导致无聊。所以这有点像混合包，是的，可能在某些情况下，更聪明的人在发现具有挑战性的认知要求任务时更有优势。有趣而不是无聊。我们知道保罗·西尔维亚的研究表明，要对某事感到兴趣，必须存在某种差距，你还不理解它，但你觉得你可以理解它。智力对此有帮助。但它也使你更容易受到这种其他无聊来源的影响。所以我认为，你赢了一些，也输了一些。理论上，你会
There's this huge gap between what you are doing and what you could be doing. And when that happens, we find it hard to pay attention and that causes boredom. So it's sort of a mixed bag that like, yeah, there may be some instances where more intelligent people have a leg up on finding, challenging sort of cognitively demanding tasks. interesting rather than boring. We know work from Paul Sylvia suggests that to feel interest in something, there has to be sort of a gap there where you don't understand it yet, but you feel like you can understand it. And intelligence helps with that. But it also makes you more prone to this other source of boredom. And so I think it's, you win some, you lose some. In theory, you would
认为更聪明的人会更善于想出解决无聊的方法。但我们没有看到情绪调节（我们称之为情绪调节）与智力之间存在强有力的联系。例如，从我们拥有的非常有限的证据来看，一旦你感到无聊，你的认知资源（即智力）是否会影响你是否善于逃避这一点，似乎并非如此。当你审视无聊的问题时，你们是否也在观察是什么让一个人变得无聊？这是你们检查过的事情吗？我们可以治疗无聊的人吗？
think that people who sort of how are smarter would be better at coming up. with ways to fix boredom once it comes up. But what we don't see are strong ties between emotion regulation, as we call it, when it comes to boredom and intelligence. It doesn't seem like the case, for instance, necessarily from the very limited evidence that we have, that once you are bored, that your sort of cognitive resources kind of intelligence is going to influence whether or not you're good at escaping that. As you look at the question of boredom, do you all, are you, are you, You're also looking at what makes an individual boring. Is that something that you have examined? Can we treat people who are boring?
是的，我们有。这些都没有发表。它仍然是非常探索性的。凯伦·加斯帕和同事们正在研究这个问题，这表明当有人在谈话中让我们感到无聊时，我们对他们的评价很差。我一直在做关于我称之为“只有无聊的人才无聊”的工作，我以为。
Yes, we have. None of this is published. It's still very exploratory. There's some work that Karen Gaspar and colleagues are doing on this question that suggests that when someone borers us in conversation, we think badly of them. There's also work that I've been doing on what I call the only boring people or boring or only boring people get bored, I thought.
是的。也就是，对，这种想法是如果你感到无聊，你一定有什么问题。而你身上出的问题可能就是你是一个无聊的人。所以我一直在观察人们关于无聊的人是什么样的刻板印象？你对无聊的人有什么看法？人们要为自己的无聊负责吗？所有这些工作都非常初步。所以我们现在还没有好的答案。但我目前能告诉你的是，你的猜测或直觉看起来与我们在人们如何评价无聊的人以及谁看起来对他们无聊方面所看到的情况相当一致。有研究，我喜欢这项工作，所以我只是
Yeah. Which is, right, this idea that if you're bored, there must be something wrong with you. And the thing that's wrong with you is probably that you're a boring person. And so I've been looking at people's stereotypes about what is a boring person like? What do you think about boring people? Are people responsible for their own boredom? And all of that work is very preliminary. So we don't have good answers. right now. But what I can tell you so far is that what you are sort of lay guesses or intuition look like are pretty consistent with what we're seeing in how people are rating boring people and who seems boring to them. There is work, and I love this work, so I'm just
要把它放在这里，如果你担心自己很无聊，那么你可能并不像你想象的那么无聊。佩吉·克拉克和同事们有很棒的研究表明，我们都有一种“喜欢差距”，我们都认为自己比实际更不有趣、更无聊、更不可爱。但如果你真的让我们互相交谈并问你的伴侣你表现如何，他们往往会更积极地评价你。所以当涉及到担心自己很无聊时，你可能并不像你想象的那么无聊。听到这个很高兴，特别是对于那些现在每天被关在同一群人里的人来说。对。你知道，我也在看你一直在做的关于分类的工作，我觉得这很有趣，因为我是一个观鸟者。
going to drop it in here, that if you're worried about being boring, the chances are that you're not as boring as you think you are. There's great work by Peggy Clark and colleagues that show that there's this sort of liking gap that we all kind of think that we're like less interesting and more boring and less likable than we actually are. But if you actually put us in conversations with each other and ask your partner how you were, they tend to sort of rate you more positively. So when it comes to worrying about you being boring, you're probably not as boring as you think you are. That's good to hear, especially for people who are kind of locked up with the same people day after day right now. Right. You know, I was also looking at the work that you've been doing around categorization, which I found interesting because I'm a birder.
所以当我没有被困在房子里时，我的意思是，我喜欢出去看鸟，有些人认为这很疯狂。但为什么收集和分类对我们中的一些人来说很有趣，而我们中的一些人却觉得它本质上有意义？我很高兴你问这个。我有一个问题，你有最喜欢的鸟吗？哦，哇，那很难。在我住的地方，我喜欢看到的鸟之一，特别是在每年的这个时候，雄性木鸭，我觉得它们太美了。但是，我的意思是，有太多了，凤尾绿咬鹃。我的意思是，怎么可能，你知道，但玫瑰琵鹭，我可以一直说鸟类。
So when I'm not stuck in the house, I mean, I like to go out and look at birds and some people think that that's crazy. But why are collecting and categorizing interesting to some of us and some of us find it inherently meaningful? I love that you ask this. I have a question for you have a favorite bird. Oh, wow, that's hard. Where I live, one of the birds that I love to see, particularly this time of year, the male wood ducks, I think they're so beautiful. But, I mean, there's so many, resplendent ketzal. I mean, how could, you know, but rosyate spoonbill, I could go on and on with birds.
你看，现在我要变得无聊了。我知道。所以玫瑰琵鹭刚来到佛罗里达。所以我一直非常，我在所有封锁事情发生之前出去看了它们。那非常令人兴奋。我问你，因为我认为那些喜欢鸟的人，你可以分享。听到它，对吧？这很令人兴奋。由于这种研究兴趣，我开始接触观鸟，因为我正在研究分类。我真的被多少人震惊了，
You see, now I'm going to get boring. I know. So the rosyate spoonbills just came to Florida. So I've been very, I went out to see them right before all the lockdown stuff happened. That was very exciting. And I ask you, because I think people who are in deport birds, you can share. hear it, right? It's exciting. And I have gotten into birding as a result of this research interest because I was looking at categorization. I was really struck by how many people,
当我在讲座中谈到这一点时，我总是问观众，这里有人是观鸟者或鸟类爱好者吗？不可避免地有一两个人举手，通常有点害羞。我们名声不好。然后我让它变得更糟。我说，成年人出去数世界上的东西不是很搞笑吗？但它以最美妙的方式。就像我认为这绝对美妙。我认为这里发生的事情是我们已经做了许多研究。我们现在正在写这个以供发表，分类为我们做了什么。
when I talk about this in lectures, I always ask the audience, does anyone hear, is anyone here a bird watcher or a birder? And inevitably one or two people kind of raise their hands, often kind of shyly. We get a bad rap. And then I make it worse. I'm like, isn't it hilarious that grown adults go out and like count things like in the world. But it is in the most wonderful of ways. Like I think it's absolutely wonderful. And I think what's happening here is we've done a number of studies. We're writing this up for publication right now that what categorization does for us.
通过分类，我的意思是任何这些分类爱好，比如收集贝壳、观鸟。这项工作实际上受到了一次去洪都拉斯的水肺潜水旅行的启发，我带了。在船上带了一张鱼类识别图，每个人都在取笑我，直到我们进入水中，然后他们都想要我的身份卡。但我没有了。我说，好吧，它在船上。你会想知道这些信息。我们认为正在发生的事情是，当你看到某物时，特别是某物
And by categorization, I mean any of these categorization hobbies, so shell collecting, bird watching. This work was actually inspired by a scuba diving trip to Honduras where I brought. got a fish identification chart with me on the boat and everyone was making fun of me until we got in the water and then they all wanted my identity card. And I didn't have it anymore. And I was like, well, it's on the boat. You'd want to know this information. And we think what's happening is that when you see something, especially something that
你没有很好的概念，或者对你来说没有意义，或者你还没有弄明白。分类是一种帮助你字面上在世界上创造秩序和连贯性的方法。想象一下，例如，你不是一个观鸟者，你刚刚听到了我们关于所有这些鸟类的谈话，你只是觉得，哦，天哪，有这么多鸟。分类让你做的是将其分解为，哦，不，有这种鸟，有那种鸟，有那种鸟。我们知道，当我们看到世界上的模式时，它们对我们来说感觉很有意义。
doesn't, you don't have a good conception of or that doesn't make sense to you or you haven't made sense of. Categorization is a way of helping you literally create order and coherence in the world. That imagine, for instance, you're not a birder and you just heard our conversation about all these birds and you're just like, oh, my God, there's just all these birds. What categorization lets you do is break that down into like, oh, no, there's this kind of bird and there's this kind of bird and there's this kind of bird. And we know that when we see patterns in the world, they feel meaningful to us.
模式给了我们一种意义感，无论是能够识别和看到野花或鸟类中的模式，还是仅仅是我们自己的日常习惯。萨曼莎·海因泽尔曼有很棒的研究表明，生活中更有规律的人在生活中体验到更多的意义。而且当他们从事这些常规时，他们也觉得自己的生活更有意义。我们非常重视这种。这种可预测性和连贯性。这就是分类给我们的，当我们看着世界上这个巨大的混乱，然后我们可以整理它并把它放进小盒子里，这让我们理解正在发生的事情。
That patterns give us a sense of meaning, whether it's being able to sort of recognize and see patterns in the wildflowers or the birds or just even our own daily routines. Samantha Heinzelman has wonderful work that shows that people who have more routine in their lives experience more meaning in life. And they also feel like their lives are more meaningful while they're engaged in those routines. We really value this kind of. kind of predictability and coherence. And that's what categorization gives us is when we look at this big sort of mess out there in the world and then we can order it and put it into little boxes that lets us make sense of what's happening.
我们体验到那种理解正在发生的事情的感觉作为一种意义感。这对我们大多数人来说是一种非常强大的感觉。而且，因为意义与无聊有关，它减少了无聊并增加了兴趣和享受。我认为这很好。我的意思是，它让我想起和能识别植物的人一起在树林里散步，这与仅仅走路、看而不了解你所看到的东西是不同的体验。就像参观艺术博物馆并有讲解员或戴上耳机，这样你就了解你正在看的东西。这当然很有意义。不，这完全是不同的体验。你知道，在社会心理学中，我们谈论很多关于解释，你的情绪、行为和思想是由你的解释塑造的。或者说你对所见事物的理解。当你看到这幅画时，分类会改变这一点，
And we experience that sense of making sense of what's happening as a sense of meaning. And that's a really powerful feeling for most of us. And it also, because meaning is related to boredom, it reduces boredom and increases interest and enjoyment. I think that's great. I mean, it reminds me of taking walks in the woods with somebody who can identify plants, how that's a different experience from just walking and looking and not knowing what you're seeing. Just taking a tour of an art museum and having a docent or getting the headphones so that you understand what you're looking at. It certainly makes a lot of sense. No, it's a completely different experience. You know, in social psychology, we talk a lot about construals and that your emotions and behavior and thoughts are shaped on your constrified. or sort of understanding of what you're seeing. And categorization changes that when you see this painting as,
当你理解它的全部历史意义时，或者你理解那个奇怪的小丑植物实际上是一种非常罕见且有价值的本地物种，它吃蚂蚁或类似疯狂的东西。在每一个层面上，这都是一种根本不同的体验。你还对拖延症进行了研究，我不得不说，你似乎试图对我们做的很多被认为不重要且没有社会用处的事情进行积极的解读。但你对拖延症有什么了解？这是否源于你对无聊的研究？
when you understand its full historical significance, or you understand that that weird little ugly plant there is actually a really rare and valuable native species that eats ants or something insane. It's a fundamentally different experience on every single level. You've also done research into procrastination, which I have to say it kind of seems like you're trying to put a positive spin on a lot of stuff we do that gets a bad rap for being unimportant and not socially useful. But what are you learning about procrastination? And that grow out of your work on boredom?
所以拖延症，心理学中有一句谚语，对吧，研究就是搜索。我作为一名本科生在我参加的一门关于动机和自我调节的课程中开始研究拖延症，因为我想做那个。理解为什么我总是拖延。我发现非常有趣的是，我上了一所非常小的文理学院，那里有一种非常强烈的学术认同感，人们非常重视，你知道，这种智力生活和学术本身的理念。所以它表现为很多学术吹嘘，但不是像我得了好成绩，而是像我熬夜到凌晨6点写论文。就像，另一个人说，哦，是的，我没有
So procrastination, there's a saying in psychology, right, that research is knee search. I started working on procrastination as an undergraduate in a course that I took on motivation and self-regulation because I want to do that. understand why I procrastinated all the time. And what I found it was really interesting is I went to a really small liberal arts college where there was this really strong sort of sense of academic identity and people really valued, you know, this idea of the intellectual life and academia for its own sake. And so it manifested in a lot of like academic bragging, but like not like I got a good grade, but like I stayed up until 6 a.m. working on my paper. Like, and someone else was like, oh yeah, I haven't
在48小时内离开图书馆。我的大学实际上开始在凌晨2点关闭图书馆以防止这种疯狂的行为。我对这个问题变得非常感兴趣，因为我注意到我的许多同学会吹嘘过去一周除了写这篇论文什么都没做，结果却挂了他们一半的课程。我心想，好吧，是否有可能你可以在不被我们通常概念化为拖延症的方式中拖延。所以我们经常想到拖延症，
left the library in 48 hours. My college actually started closing the library at 2 a.m. to prevent this kind of like insane behavior. And I became really interested in this question because what I noticed was that many of my peers that would brag about like having done nothing but work on this paper for the past week would be failing half their classes. And I was like, well, is it possible that you can procrastinate in. ways that aren't what we typically conceptualize procrastination as. So we often think of procrastination,
对，就是代替做你应该做的事情，你跑去看了Netflix，或者你去参加聚会，或者你知道，你做了一些有趣且琐碎的事情。但那不是我在那所大学看到的学生们做的事情。我看到他们做的是拖延他们真正应该做的事情，但他们通过做非常重要的事情来拖延。他们做其他重要的学校作业作为避免他们因某种原因推迟的任务的一种方式。所以我开始对我称之为“生产性拖延”的问题感兴趣。我的意思是，通过做另一件仍然有价值的事情来拖延某事。所以就像我说的，学习考试而不是看Netflix
right, is that instead of doing the thing you're supposed to be doing, you go off and watch Netflix or you go to a party or you know, you do something that's sort of like fun and trivial. But that wasn't what I saw the students doing at this college. What I saw them doing was procrastinating on things that they really should have been doing, but they were procrastinating by doing a very important things. They were doing other important schoolwork as a way of avoiding this task that they were putting off for some reason. And so I became interested in what I call productive procrastination. And by that, I mean procrastinating on something by doing something else that still has values. So like I said, studying for an exam instead of watching Netflix
或者它不必在同一个领域。你可以通过做另一项学术任务来拖延一项学术任务，那可能是生产性的。但你也可以通过洗衣服、洗碗、烤面包或做一些生产性但不一定是学术性的事情来拖延那项学术任务。所以我对这个问题并不真正感兴趣，比如，一，这是一件真实的事情，还是我只是在编造它？人们真的从事这些不同种类的拖延吗？二，如果他们这样做，如果他们这样做，它是否像
or it doesn't have to be in the same domain. You can procrastinate on one academic task by working on another academic task and that could be productive. But you can also procrastinate on that academic task by doing the laundry or washing the dishes or baking bread or doing something that's productive but not necessarily academic. And so I'm not really interested in this question of like, one, is this a real thing or am I just sort of like making this up? Like do people actually engage in these different kinds of procrastination? And two, if they do, if they do is is it as bad as
这些经典的拖延方式一样糟糕，比如为了去和朋友聚会或看电视而放弃工作。我们发现的是双重的。所以首先，人们绝对报告说他们这样做。而且这个想法在流行文化中随处可见。拖延烘焙，对吧？这完全是
these classic ways of procrastinating like blowing off your work to go party with friends or watch TV. And what we found was like twofold. So first of all, people absolutely report doing this. And this idea is out there everywhere in pop culture. Procrastabaking, right? It's totally
这些经典的拖延方式，比如为了和朋友聚会或看电视而把工作抛在脑后。我们发现的情况是双重的。首先，人们确实报告了这种行为。而且这种观念在流行文化中随处可见。比如“拖延式烘焙”，对吧？这完全是
a phrase that people use. It was in the New York Times not too long ago. It's like a guide to procrastinate baking. And we see people talk about it in everyday life, but we don't see it showing up in their research. So we just designed a study asking people, very descriptive, qualitative-ish study, basically looking at whether people first just do this, and they do. It is as common, if not more common than these sort of old-school traditional ideas of procrastination,
这是一个人们常用的短语。不久前《纽约时报》还提到过它。它就像是一份拖延烘焙的指南。我们在日常生活中看到人们谈论它，但在研究中却很少见到。所以我们设计了一项研究来询问人们，这是一项非常具有描述性的定性研究，主要是观察人们是否真的会这样做，结果他们确实会。这种拖延方式和那些传统的拖延观念一样普遍，甚至更常见，
where you put off one important task by doing something unimportant or a blow-off thing instead. people were just as likely to say that they are putting off academic tasks by doing work for other classes or putting off a hard assignment by doing an easier assignment or putting off school work by cleaning the dishes. That was just as common as these kinds as watching Netflix or doing something that had no point. And it's not just college students. Most of the work that we've done has been in academia and academics, both for convenience and because that's where it's an obvious issue. But we've also done some work, for instance, with visitors to the North Carolina State Fair, which is a much broader group of people. It's just people that went to the fair and agreed to participate in a psych study. And we see similar rates when you ask about procrastinating on tasks at work or procrastinating on tasks around the home.
即通过做一些不重要或敷衍了事的事情来推迟一项重要任务。人们同样倾向于说，他们通过做其他课程的作业来推迟学术任务，或者通过做简单的作业来推迟困难的作业，又或者通过洗碗来推迟学校的功课。这与看网飞（Netflix）或做一些毫无意义的事情一样普遍。而且这不仅仅是大学生的问题。我们所做的大部分工作都是在学术界和学者身上进行的，既是为了方便，也是因为这是一个显而易见的问题。但我们也做了一些工作，例如，针对北卡罗来纳州博览会的游客，这是一个更广泛的群体。他们只是去参加博览会并同意参与心理学研究的人。当我们询问关于工作或家务中的拖延任务时，我们看到了相似的比例。
So, for instance, I have still not filed my IRS returns. I'm absolutely procrastinating on that. But I feel justified because I've been working on great applications. Well, and they changed the deadline this year, too. Oh, no, they changed the deadline. I will pretend like that's the reason why. But it also sounds like an issue of prioritization. I mean, I certainly work with people who, if you don't tell them, look, this is the most
所以，举个例子，我还没有申报我的国税局（IRS）税表。我绝对是在拖延这件事。但我感到理直气壮，因为我一直在忙于申请资助。嗯，而且他们今年还更改了截止日期。哦，不，他们更改了截止日期。我会假装那是原因。但这听起来也像是一个优先级排序的问题。我的意思是，我确实和一些人一起工作，如果你不告诉他们，看，这是最
important thing you need to do today that they don't understand that they'll do the thing that's maybe fifth or sixth down the list in my mind. I mean, is that different or is that the same kind of procrastination? I think it's subjective. I think it counts as procrastination when you know you should be doing it, but choose not to. So if you legitimately don't think you should be doing it, so I think that's actually why this is a great example. I think the tax return is procrastination in my case because I am, I know I should be doing it and I'm deliberately putting it off by doing other things and make me feel better about it not doing it. But someone else, my father also hasn't filed his tax return, isn't planning to do so until the end of it. April. But in his case, he rationally looked at the extended deadline and said, you know what, like, it makes sense for me to wait and do this later because this is other really important stuff I have to do. And in that case, I would say that is not procrastinating. He does, he's not putting it off. He doesn't think he should do it now. He very legitimately has simply reordered
重要的事情，你今天需要做，他们就不明白，他们会去做我心目中排在第五或第六位的事情。我的意思是，这有什么不同，还是说这是同一种拖延？我认为这是主观的。我认为当你明知应该做某事却选择不做时，这就属于拖延。所以，如果你真的认为你不应该做它，我认为这实际上就是为什么这是一个很好的例子。我认为在我的情况下，报税是拖延，因为我知道我应该做，但我故意通过做其他事情来推迟它，这让我感觉好受一些。但其他人，比如我父亲，他也没有申报税表，打算等到四月底才做。但在他的情况下，他理性地看待了延长的截止日期，并说，你知道吗，推迟到以后再做对我来说是有意义的，因为我还有其他非常重要的事情要做。在这种情况下，我会说那不是拖延。他并没有推迟。他不认为他现在应该做。他非常合理地重新安排了
his priorities to reflect. It's a conscious decision. Yes. And so I think procrastination is in some a subjective state that it depends on the psychology of why people are doing it and how they feel about it. The good news, this is very preliminary, but we do have data that for academic procrastination, at least, that I'm not going to go so far as to say you should do productive procrastination. That's definitely too far. But when we compare people that don't procrastinate at all, which is an embarrassingly large percentage of humanity, I've discussed. hard. I know, depending on the study, it's like 25 to 30, 40% of people that like, you know,
他的优先级以反映这一点。这是一个有意识的决定。是的。所以我认为拖延在某种程度上是一种主观状态，它取决于人们为什么这样做以及他们对此的感受。好消息是，虽然这非常初步，但我们确实有数据表明，至少对于学术拖延而言，我不会走得太远说你应该进行生产性拖延。那绝对太过分了。但当我们比较那些完全不拖延的人时，这在人类中占了令人尴尬的很大比例，我讨论过。很难。我知道，根据研究，大约有25%到30%、40%的人，你知道，
everyone's human, but by and large, they tend not to procrastinate. When you look at people that engage in a lot of productive procrastination, so putting off their taxes to apply for grants or putting off studying for an exam to work on a paper assignment, they don't look any different in terms of their college GPAs. Their GPAs look about the same. doesn't look like their grades are suffering because of this decision overall. The other thing that we find is that when you engage in productive procrastination in this way, it doesn't seem like it puts you at risk for alcohol use and risky alcohol drinking
每个人都是人，但总的来说，他们倾向于不拖延。当你观察那些进行大量生产性拖延的人时，比如推迟报税去申请资助，或者推迟复习考试去写论文，他们的大学平均绩点（GPA）并没有什么不同。他们的GPA看起来差不多。总的来说，他们的成绩似乎并没有因为这个决定而受到影响。我们发现的另一件事是，当你以这种方式进行生产性拖延时，它似乎不会让你面临酒精使用和危险饮酒的风险，
in the same way that we often see with other forms of procrastination. So that classic procrastination where you blow off your schoolwork to go party or go watch Netflix, that's associated with a lot of problems just with self-regulation in general and self-control in general. And we see a lot of correlations there between people that procrastinate in those ways and increased risk of alcohol use disorder, increased risk of hazards, just drinking in college, you know, binge drinking, all that sort of stuff tends to go along as a package with that behavioral profile. And that's really not what we see for the productive procrastinators. I'm writing up a paper right now. But our current
这与我们经常看到的其他形式的拖延不同。那种经典的拖延，即你为了去聚会或看网飞而推迟学业，这与一般的自我调节和自我控制问题有关。我们看到那些以这种方式拖延的人与酒精使用障碍风险增加、危险风险增加之间存在很多相关性，只是在大学里喝酒，你知道，酗酒，所有这些事情往往与那种行为特征捆绑在一起。而这真的不是我们在生产性拖延者身上看到的。我正在写一篇论文。但我们目前的
thinking is that productive procrastination may be an unorthodox but acceptable variant that people use to emotionally cope with tasks that are difficult and hard for them to do in some way that at least you're not totally disengaging. You know, if I'm having a really hard time on this school assignment and I decided to work on this other assignment for school, I'm still engaged academically. I'm not losing my overall academic motivation. And I may be better prepared to circle back and work on that original task that I put off at a later date. So productive procrastination, I don't go so far as to say that a positive or a good thing, but I don't think it's a bad thing and I don't think people need to feel as guilty about that kind of procrastination as they do for, you know, just blowing it
想法是，生产性拖延可能是一种非正统但可以接受的变体，人们用它来在情感上应对那些对他们来说在某种程度上困难和艰巨的任务，至少你没有完全脱离。你知道，如果我在这个学校作业上遇到了很大的困难，而我决定去做学校的另一个作业，我仍然在学术上保持参与。我没有失去整体的学术动力。而且我可能为以后回头处理我推迟的原始任务做好了更好的准备。所以生产性拖延，我不会说它是一件积极或好的事情，但我不认为它是一件坏事，我不认为人们需要为那种拖延感到像他们为，你知道，只是把一切都
all off and going and doing something fun instead. Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense. Any final words of advice for our listeners who might be feeling bored or maybe putting off doing things that they could be doing right now? Yeah, so I'm going to tackle those separately because I have two sets of tips. One for procrastination, Alexandra Forrand and Zurich has fabulous data showing that there's a really nifty trick that you can do with procrastination to help. And I read about this in the research literature. I cite it in my papers all the time and I use it in my own life. And I've personally replicated it with a sample of one many times. And I find it helpful. And the idea is that a lot of times when you're dreading doing a task, there's two different reasons you might dread doing it.
抛在脑后去做有趣的事情那样感到内疚。是的。是的。这很有道理。对于那些可能感到无聊或者可能推迟做他们现在可以做的事情的听众，有什么最后的建议吗？是的，我要分别处理这些问题，因为我有两套建议。一套是关于拖延的，苏黎世的亚历山德拉·福兰德（Alexandra Forrand）有很棒的数据表明，有一个非常巧妙的技巧可以帮助解决拖延问题。我在研究文献中读到过这个。我经常在我的论文中引用它，我也在自己的生活中使用它。我个人已经用一个样本多次复制了它。我觉得它很有帮助。这个想法是，很多时候当你害怕做一项任务时，你害怕做它可能有两个不同的原因。
You might dread actually doing it. Like, oh, I don't want to sit down and do this super monotonous complicated thing. Or you might dread doing it because the stakes are so high. Like, oh, I know it's just this one little email to send to someone, but I'm really worried about how they're going to respond. And if they respond badly, it's going to ruin everything. And so what Alexander Foren finds is that if you can figure out why you're putting it off, You can focus on the other thing instead. So if you don't want to do your taxes because I don't want to go and find all the little forms and do all the little numbers and like, where is my W2?
你可能害怕真正去做它。比如，哦，我不想坐下来做这个超级单调复杂的事情。或者你可能害怕做它是因为风险太高了。比如，哦，我知道这只是发给某人的一封小邮件，但我真的很担心他们会如何回应。如果他们回应得很糟糕，一切都会被毁掉。所以亚历山大·福兰德发现，如果你能弄清楚你为什么推迟它，你就可以专注于另一件事。所以如果你不想报税，因为我不想去找出所有的小表格并计算所有的小数字，比如，我的W2表格在哪里？
Oh, I moved institutions. I need to find my lat. You know, all these little, like the nitty gritty details. By shifting my focus to why I'm doing it, the bigger overarching abstract goal, like, oh, you know, I'm going to get a tax grade fund. I'm going to not get in trouble with the IRS. That can increase motivation and make it easier to ask. actually just get started and do the tasks. So if you're put off by the detail, the nitty-gritty details, focusing on the bigger reason for why you're doing it helps. And conversely, if you're
哦，我换了机构。我需要找到我的……你知道，所有这些琐碎的细节。通过将我的注意力转移到我为什么要做它，即更大的总体抽象目标，比如，哦，你知道，我会得到退税。我不会惹上国税局的麻烦。这可以增加动力，使它更容易开始并完成任务。所以如果你被细节、琐碎的细节所困扰，专注于你做这件事的更大原因会有所帮助。反之，如果你
putting it off because the big reason that you're doing it is so, you know, stressful or overwhelming, it helps to instead shift to the nitty-gritty details and be like, okay, like, you know, instead of focusing about like how this email is going to make or break my career, I'm just going to focus on writing it one word at a time. And that kind of shift in level, helps people fix the problem. And I think that's actually a valuable lesson for boredom in general, because often, not always, but procrastination is about anticipating that something's going to make you feel anxious or anticipating that something's going to make you feel bored.
推迟它是因为你做这件事的大原因太，你知道，压力大或令人不知所措，那么转而关注琐碎的细节会有所帮助，比如，好吧，你知道，与其担心这封邮件会如何成就或毁掉我的职业生涯，我不如专注于逐字逐句地写它。这种层面的转变有助于人们解决问题。我认为这对一般的无聊也是一个有价值的教训，因为通常，虽然不是总是，拖延是关于预期某事会让你感到焦虑或预期某事会让你感到无聊。
And we know that we can reduce boredom by fixing the problems that caused it. So we open today where it's talking about how boredom signals that you're not able to pay attention or that what you're doing doesn't feel meaning. But that also gives you the information you need to stop. feeling bored. If you feel bored because what you're doing doesn't have meaning, maybe you should either go do something else or find a way to see the meaning in what you're doing. So for right now, for instance, we're all under these stay-at-home orders and that doesn't feel like we're doing much. It doesn't feel super meaningful. I know it is objectively, but it doesn't feel that way. So anything we can do
我们知道我们可以通过解决导致无聊的问题来减少无聊。所以我们今天开篇谈到了无聊如何发出信号，表明你无法集中注意力，或者你正在做的事情感觉没有意义。但这也为你提供了停止感到无聊所需的信息。如果你感到无聊是因为你正在做的事情没有意义，也许你应该去做别的事情，或者找到一种方法来看出你正在做的事情的意义。所以就目前而言，例如，我们都处于这些居家令之下，这感觉不像我们在做很多事情。它感觉不是特别有意义。我知道客观上它是，但感觉并非如此。所以任何我们能做的
to remind ourselves and keep that right frame in mind that what I'm doing right now, literally by sitting at my desk is saving lives. Right, right. You know, any way that you can increase the meaning of what you're doing, whether it's a reminder on the fridge or talking about it with others, it literally makes us feel less bored because it infuses everything you're doing with a sense of meaning. And that sort of quiets down all those sort of like parts of your mind that are
提醒自己并保持正确的框架，即我现在所做的，仅仅通过坐在桌子前，就是在拯救生命。对，对。你知道，任何你能增加你所做事情意义的方法，无论是冰箱上的提醒还是与他人谈论它，它确实让我们感觉不那么无聊，因为它为你所做的一切注入了一种意义感。这在某种程度上平息了你心中那些
alerting you that what you're doing isn't meaningful because you're saying, yes, yes, it is. And the same thing goes for attention, that if you're having trouble concentrating because things are too hard right now, it's okay to listen to that signal and back off and, you know, step it down to a level that you can handle or conversely if you don't have enough to occupy your days, sort of use it as license. If that's where you're at, not everyone is, but if you're at that point where you want to engage in some new hobbies or download that book you've always been meeting during, that can be a great fit for people, too. I think fixing
提醒你所做的事情没有意义的部分，因为你在说，是的，是的，它是有意义的。同样的情况也适用于注意力，如果你因为现在事情太难而难以集中注意力，听从那个信号并退后一步，你知道，把它降低到你能处理的水平是可以的，或者反之，如果你没有足够的事情来占据你的日子，把它当作一种许可。如果那是你所处的状态，并不是每个人都是这样，但如果你处于那种想要尝试一些新爱好或下载你一直想读的那本书的状态，这对人们来说也是一个很好的选择。我认为解决
boredom and fixing procrastination are really about listening to your emotions and listening to the information that those emotions are trying to tell you. We have this idea that emotions are irrational and they're not. They're so rational. They're like our internal messaging service to tell us what's going on with our minds. And by listening to them, we can get that information and use that information to fix them and feel better. Well, that's all great advice. So Dr. Westgate, thank you so much for joining speaking of psychology. I have to say I found our conversation to be anything but boring. So thank you. Thank you so much. That's always my fear. And for our listeners, if you have any comments or ideas that you want to share with our podcast,
无聊和解决拖延实际上是关于倾听你的情绪，并倾听这些情绪试图告诉你的信息。我们有一种观念认为情绪是不理性的，但它们不是。它们非常理性。它们就像我们内部的消息服务，告诉我们我们的思想发生了什么。通过倾听它们，我们可以获得这些信息，并利用这些信息来修复它们并感觉更好。嗯，这些建议都很棒。所以韦斯特盖特博士，非常感谢你加入《心理学谈话》。我必须说，我发现我们的谈话一点也不无聊。所以谢谢你。非常感谢。那一直是我担心的。对于我们的听众，如果你有任何想与我们的播客分享的评论或想法，
you can send an email to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website and download all the episodes at www. www.combeatingof Psychology.org. Thanks again for listening for the American Psychological. Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，所有单词连在一起，在 APA.org。你可以在苹果、Stitcher、Spotify 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。你也可以访问我们的网站并下载所有剧集，网址是 www.combeatingof Psychology.org。再次感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。